this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host my co-host
today christy wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling
author of the book business boutique and
of course the host of the business
boutique event
as well and we're gonna be taking your
calls about your life and your money
triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five
five two two five well america ramsey is
freaking
open for business christy i'm so pumped
that we're back on the road yes doing
events again
and this is what lots of events this is
what we do
how much until i couldn't do them
anymore i know i know and then you the
first one back you're like oh there it
is
that's what we've been missing man so we
got two big event announcements
today that we want to cut you guys in on
number one we will be in dallas for the
entree leadership
summit next week may the 16th
through the 19th now entre leadership
summit
is arguably the best leadership event
in america today it is one of the top
five for sure
by anybody's calculation it is a
phenomenal experience
top to bottom the way the attendees are
treated the things that we do
for them and we bring in absolutely
world-class speakers you'll be speaking
yes
i'm so every year and this is my one of
my favorite events because of exactly
what you said
the time money and intentionality that
we put into this event
is unlike anything else we do it's
massive yeah i mean this
even the screens are massive everything
about it is just
unbelievable over the top so i'll uh you
know ken coleman will be with us a bunch
of our ramsey personalities dr john
deloney's doing a session as well
christy me george will be there courtney
will be there
i'm looking forward to doing a couple of
sessions uh and we've got
just unbelievable news we just
were released by the secret service to
be able to tell you that george w bush
will be joining us yes oh it's going to
be
awesome that's over the top uh jocko
will ink will be with us uh
man and he's a former navy seal
best-selling author
absolute incredible uh john maxwell
i mean papa john right leadership
john but i mean he's the he's like he's
you know people are going to be ordering
pizza now
yeah he's the top one of the top
leadership speakers of all time
and writers of 80 plus best-selling
books
pastor craig groschel spoke last year
and back this year
uh pastor of uh i think america's
largest church at this point
lifechurch.tv
and uh our life.church now they call it
pat lincione back
a fan favorite of our tribe you can
never mess up with pat best-selling
author marcus buckingham best-selling
author of the strength finders
series and he'll be speaking this is his
second time to be with us
absolutely over the top lineup i mean
jocko maxwell
grochelle lincione buckingham oh dr
adrian sternberg will be with us for the
first time
uh she spoke here a few weeks ago at one
of our devotionals and
brought the house down yes she's a she's
a force of nature she is and from the
very first words out of her mouth
every single person in the room was
leaning in like she had us yeah she's
that good
yeah she's really good so the problem is
you guys
it's completely sold out they're like
wait why are you telling us this
it's completely sold out i mean uh and
with a waiting list to get into the room
and so um
there's enough people that are out there
when america opens up that want to do
stuff that
it's um i mean we're gonna have about 2
500 folks in the auditorium
in the uh room with us and uh absolutely
incredible
but here's what we're doing we're gonna
live stream it
and we're gonna allow you guys in
business that want to have
a three-day leadership bootcamp with the
best minds on the planet
talking to them uh you know we're
shutting down
all of our leadership team here in
nashville uh there's almost 200 of them
in our leadership team
and we're putting them in a room to
watch this live stream yeah
we believe in it that much yeah and
we're gonna uh so we're investing
heavily in that and if you want to do
that with your team
out there uh and have it live streamed
in you can do that for one price and
just
buy a license and you can watch it with
two people or 200 people
whatever you want to do inside your
office and we want to make sure this
information is available because this
lineup
i mean george w bush jocko maxwell
grocelle lincione buckingham
sternberg ken coleman christy wright
john deloney
me this is this is a week of leadership
yeah at its best yeah i mean i i'll bet
you
uh i haven't added it up but i'll bet
you it's over
i bet it's approaching 200 million book
sales oh
among that line oh i believe it because
these guys have sold
just tens of millions of books it's
amazing
so if you want to be involved in this
lineup
and watch it the live stream to register
text the word summit to 44
222 our guys will help you out with a
site license for you to be able to watch
with your whole team
it's not unreasonable especially when
you consider what you would have paid if
you were in the room
especially when you consider this lineup
you really would pay this
to watch one of these people yeah that's
what it amounts to so
text summit to 44 222
and we're announcing today the launch of
business boutique goes on sale for the
fall
yes coming up in the fall people have
been asking me like
crazy about this dave and today is the
big launch day
yes we're doing it again like we do it
every single fall
back here in nashville which is a great
city for a
ladies trip a girls trip come with your
friend come
bring your spouse if you want to but
it's october 14th through the 16th
so in the fall here in nashville and and
what's so cool about this
event dave and we've talked about this
we've seen it year after year is we have
amazing speakers
and people come for the amazing speakers
that are experts on everything from
money management to marketing to selling
social media
everything you need to start or grow
your business whether it's a side
business or a small
business or you've got team members we
want to give you what you need to win
but what's so amazing is what happens in
that room
goes far beyond the sessions and the
information
and you've seen this because i know
because you've attended you've spoken it
but you have seen there's a
transformation in their level of
confidence
they walk out of that room ready to
charge hell with a water pistol and they
believe they can do it when you believe
you can do it you'll actually put that
stuff into practice
because even if you have all the best
information in the world if you're
scared you're going to stay stuck so
it's both it's information
and inspiration and this year we have
amazing speakers you're speaking again
and they always love having you there i
love it anthony
the business boutique conference is
equipping women to make money doing what
they love that's right so it's for women
in business
what type of business any type of
business right small business
side business freelance solopreneur
doesn't matter
if you're in business at any capacity
and you're a lady especially if you're
getting started
or don't have a team you're doing it all
yourself or you have a real small team
this is for you so anthony o'neil be
with us jasmine starr
nona jones uh bianca ulta
okay so tell us what they do so now
anthony he's gonna be speaking on money
which that's what we're known for here
you're gonna be speaking on selling
which is such a pain point gosh they
feel so uncomfortable with sales and
selling and
and i love how you always teach how it's
really serving not selling
jasmine star is an expert on social
media nona jones social media bianca
she's faith-based and we're going to
cover a lot more topics as well text
boutique
to 33 789 tickets are on sale now that
is also going to be live streamed so 119
in the room 89 as a live stream
and ladies you need to get signed up for
this quickly it will sell out very fast
we sold it out even during coveted last
fall so
text boutique to 33789
and you can text summit if you're
interested in the summit
to 44 222.
either one of those will get you going
or both of them will get you going this
is the ramsey show
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 a month
by switching
to pure top just go to feartalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
do
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about life and about money
open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five allen
is with us in lexington hey guys the
phones aren't working
uh alan's with us in lexington kentucky
are you with me alan
hey there you go alan are you with me
alex
oh good i got it okay how can we help
all right
dave i got a question for you i'm 53 my
wife's going to be 52 next month
our son's going to be 12 august our
household income this year is going to
be around
75 000 gross i have a beneficiary ira
left from my mother in 2009 which passed
that's got about
338 000 dollars in it we have a home
that's valued by our county pba at 340
thousand dollars
uh wife and i are debt free um
and i was wanting to ask you about
investing this money that's in this
beneficiary ira we've got it invested
the way
currently that you teach but because you
can't contribute to it and you have to
take an
rmd from it every year if it should be
invested any other way
other than what you teach because of
those stipulations no
it doesn't the contribution doesn't
matter the rmd is just aggravating
and they're even worse now if you got it
if you'd gotten it in 2020
or beyond you would have to drain it all
in 10 years
but you're running you're running on a
very slim rmd
uh required minimum distribution for you
folks out there don't know what he's
talking about but the uh um
yeah i would just minimize it because
every dollar you pull out of there
you're gonna have to turn it into 70
cents because the government's going to
take their
cut off the top and so i just let that
go i'd let that government tax money sit
there and earn you money until you don't
have to
now your house is paid for right
right okay everything 100 debt-free
right
yes sir yeah yeah then if i owned uh
a an inherited ira that way
um yeah thank you
uh if i owned an inherited ira uh i
would take the required minimum
and not take it any sooner than possible
because if you pull it
you know you you're turning if you if
you pull a thousand dollars out you took
a thousand dollars turned it into 700
after taxes
yeah and you could have used that whole
three that other 300 that's government
money to grow money with
explain the rmd explain the required
minimum distribution how does that work
well it used to be
at 70 and a half now it's at 72 that
you're required to begin
distributing your ira because they want
a traditional ira because they want
their tax money okay
they want to get their tax money on an
inherited ira and the rm the required
minimum distribution runs out
uh based on uh death okay
based on the uh
a little bit to where by the time you
would have died
you would have gotten it all out and
they would have gotten their tax money
that was the concept behind it
and so now at 53 well nine years ago or
whatever he inherited his mom's ira uh
you don't
you know you have to begin to take it
out as if it was at 53.
oh okay and so it's a small little
amount
progressively larger as you get older uh
that is the required minimum
distribution but the concept is the irs
wants their money yeah
and uh but we want to keep it away from
them as long as we can yeah
we're going to push it and leave
everything in there yeah as long as you
can in a traditional
now if it's a roth it changes the whole
equation obviously
uh and if you again under the new rules
if you inherited it
in 2020 or later uh you're going to have
have to drain it it's called the drain
and 10 rule uh
it's somewhat it's nickname but you have
to it's one tenth
a 10 a year for 10 years okay and
regardless if you're 22 or you're 42
you have to begin to take it out all the
way down through there like that
so uh victoria on facebook says i
recently became a certified nutrition
counselor and am working on my business
plan website what's the best way to
launch my business christy
i you know the thing that even when you
say the word launch like launch is
exciting you can do build up you can do
a big announcement but if you are
a nutrition counselor i say just get
scrappy and start telling people
email your f family and friends you know
one of the things that people
uh underestimate dave is just the simple
steps of faith so you can start with
your contact list you may not have a big
email list
you can email everyone in your contacts
say hey guys um you know i just want to
let you know i'm doing this new thing
here's my heart behind it here's my why
if this would benefit you or if you know
of anyone i would love your business
here's how to contact me and you just
start
with who you know start with your
personal facebook page until you get
your business page up and going
you can get fancy later but i think just
those initial
taking some step of action it's going to
build confidence in you and get money in
the door faster that's going to fuel
that growth versus waiting until your
website's perfect waiting until you have
a huge email list to launch
too you can do that but man i think you
can make money faster if you just get
going
yeah get organic about it and just stick
your foot out stick your foot out the
door and go
yeah and here's the other thing that's
going to happen um what you think is
going to be the thing it'll almost never
be the thing yes
and so you're going to adjust when you
get it when you put your ideas out in
the wild and actually are out there
you know with the animals doing your
thing you know then you
you start to find out that oh this
doesn't work the way i thought it did
yeah
and uh when financial peace university
started yeah
uh you know i was in a room with an
overhead projector in a bad suit but it
was called life after debt
and it was a class designed for
bankruptcy
to help people avoid bankruptcy so i
went through the types of bankruptcy in
one lesson
i went through foreclosures and how to
avoid them in another lesson
so it was for people right on the edge
or completely devastated and broke like
i had been
right uh but as the weird thing was we
had kept having
none of those people show up to the
class everybody that came to the class
was not broke they just didn't have any
money because it was all going back out
the door but they weren't on the edge of
bankruptcy or foreclosure right
and they just wanted to learn how to
handle money they want to learn how to
budget they want to learn how to invest
they want to learn how to save for
emergencies they want to learn how to
get their kids college fund going and
that kind of stuff and so
after about six months i went i got to
change this right
and i wouldn't have ever known that i
had to take out the foreclosure lesson
and take out the bankruptcy lesson
which is now in our counselor training
we'd use the same material to teach the
counselors how to do it the coaches how
to do it
our coach financial coach training and
but but
i wouldn't have ever known that had i
not just taken that leap of faith and
gotten started that's right and i love
how you always say
business is a conversation with the
marketplace well conversations happen
two ways
and i think sometimes we think well i've
got to get it all right get it all
perfect put it out there and then the
conversation's over no a conversation is
back and forth i use
the iphone example iphone we're on 10 11
12 whatever it is now
they started with the iphone one they
put it out there and the market says hey
we like this but a little more of this
can you make the camera better can you
make it slimmer
and then you guarantee when they
launched that they had no idea that the
iphone was going to be the camera of
choice for americans
yes no that the camera was going to be
the deal right and the market
told them that in that conversation but
then to your point you go back and
iterate and improve and change and take
out lessons and add the camera or
whatever
and then you put it back out there you
get better and better but it only
happens
through the conversation and a
conversation doesn't happen until you
put something out there so i say yeah
start with what you have your friends
your family if you're in a service-based
business like you're saying victoria is
a nutrition
counselor then your sweet spot is
referrals
and word of mouth and people that you
already know you like you and trust you
so i think start there but i love that
reminder that in order to have a
conversation you have to start
talking and be willing to listen to the
feedback that's where your best ideas
are going to come from well and you know
honestly when you hear me talk about
that sometimes it's around here in a
meeting and i'm saying we're having a
conversation with the marketplace the
marketplace says you suck
you know on the other
and i'm like guys you know your
customers all just yelled at you
because the sales turned down on this
they just yelled at you that this
the price point is wrong that this
concept is bad
that this product is poorly designed
even though in our best minds in some
back conference room or something and
we'd had it all figured out how this was
all perfect
until we put it out there with the
animals and then the animals went nope
no noob you missed the mark and you got
to be
you're going to mess up a prototype
never makes it to market ever yeah
without adjustments
yes and so you put the prototype in the
hands of the actual user
and see what they do with it yeah and
you know it takes twice as long
costs twice as much and you're not the
exception these are the three rules of
business so get out there and do stuff
get out there and do stuff and when in
doubt leave the cave kill something and
drag it home
but do it in such a way that when it
fails or portions of it fail
it doesn't break you right but go ahead
and start yeah
go ahead and start and be emotionally
prepared for this conversation with the
marketplace that's beautiful stuff
good stuff christy this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions
on the debt free stage matthew and heidi
here with us hey guys how are you
hey dave welcome where do you guys live
we are from grand rapids michigan
oh very cool good to have you and how
much debt have you paid off
we paid off 34 000 in 18 months
great job nice and your range of income
during that time
we started at around 88 000 and
now we're at about 120 000. cool what do
y'all do for a living
i work for a large medical device
company in marketing
and i'm a hair stylist cool what kind of
debt was your 34 000
it was student loans and car oh wow all
right
pretty simple how long you two been
married a year and a half
oh so you get married and start this
journey boom we're getting out of debt
well uh for the car she actually told me
before it was
11 000 on the car and she told me before
we got married i had to pay off the car
before the wedding date so i had a
deadline
i like it wow
okay so wait a minute you did all this
before you got married or after you got
married you've been married 18 months
you said you did this in 18 months
yeah so the car was on me i did that
for uh the 18 for the time being right
before we got married the student loans
were once we got married when we
combined the income we attacked my debt
got it okay very cool okay so heidi uh
i mean you you you threw down you're not
messing around nope that wasn't a
stipulation
i'm like get that pain no car debt no
marriage nope this is not you know wow
you're hardcore what made you
do that um it was money borrowed from
his parents and i just didn't want to
have that going into
our marriage and that relationship with
in-laws i don't want anything to start
off on the wrong foot
and he hadn't been paying on it i just
needed to go so
heidi heidi that's awesome it's also
weird
like how did you where did your where
did your how did you learn about money
how did you become
anti-debt like that's not that's awesome
and not normal at all so
you're so right and so practical but
there's nothing romantic about this
we're just confused we don't know what
to do with you i love it
yeah my parents actually taught fpu for
quite a long time so they
brought they taught that to me growing
up forever
they always had me sit down and do a
budget as soon as i got a job so
i always knew that was not something
that i wanted to have so you're a
financial piece baby then oh yeah
yeah definitely that explains it now
this makes a lot of sense now
dating the parents are dating the
daughter of coordinators
oh yeah this is a different experience
yeah i cut out for you matthew that's uh
yeah that's
the wow very cool very cool yeah he
hadn't been paying on it this just had
to go
yeah it just had to go that's so great i
love it
i love it so this how long into your
dating relationship
before you all started talking about
money issues oh that's a good question
i would say pretty soon as soon as we
started dating we were open about it
um at the time i was still in high
school he was in college so we knew
whatever we wanted to do we wanted to be
able to pay off as soon as possible
so we're always very open about it okay
all right
but matthew you got the idea pretty
quick that this was a subject that's
going to be important to this woman 100
she uh looks up to you a lot and her
parents taught your class so that's
she's the accounting by the books person
i'm the marketing go with the flow love
talking to people yeah
and so that was the hardest thing for me
was to stick to the numbers look and
excel
and look at the numbers and do that
every month yeah well you're like me you
think you can now earn your stupidity
yeah i tried to do that for years yeah
marketing guys we're all that way
i mean i love it go get more money and
go get more money right yeah you just
get some more money you just need to get
some more money that's all we need to do
yeah way to go you guys what a great way
to start your dating relationship and
then your marriage as well
what was that like for your for your
first year and a half of marriage to
work as a team to attack this debt
together
it was really helpful every single uh
right when the month ended that usually
it was that sunday we went through the
books
and just sitting down there after church
looking through everything
and adding it up and over time through
our side hustles from
delivering food through ubereats her
nannying we just started seeing the
numbers go
from two to three to just growing every
single month that we could just continue
to throw at the debt
wow that's cool brings you together as a
team you know anytime but especially
early in marriage when you're trying to
merge your lives you've got different
values beliefs like what a cool thing
to attack together dumb question but you
ever go back into debt
no not a chance not a chance
way to go you guys very cool okay now
since you grew up with this
uh uh in the case of heidi and and
matthew
you know that you've proven now in 18
months that as a brand new married
couple you can knock this debt out
tell people what the secret to getting
out of debt is i would say
the main thing is don't make excuses for
not being able to make more money
we picked up side hustles that we didn't
think were going to be super fun but we
found something that we could make more
money
and just sticking to it and just
grinding
yeah yeah and i would say uh just
working your butt off
uh i work you know normal 40 hours a
week
salary working from home during culver
is almost a blessing to be able
to do ubereats the food deliveries until
10 11 o'clock
i know yeah it was the best part and
just being able to do that and grind and
tell your friends nope can't hang out
tonight i'm delivering food
and it was always a good conversation
starter but it just showed the
dedication and everyone
could start start to see the example
that we were setting and
working with one of my friends i was
actually able to help him push him to
help pay off his car debt
all right very good it gets perpetuated
here
yeah very ripple effect very cool yeah
hustle grind hard work
uh yeah there's no substitute for that
so you did several different things what
was your best paying
side hustle ubereats definitely oh yeah
everything
what did you how much did you make and
how much did you work so and
so we started in a month in a month i
mean hours your weight or a week how
many drinks
weeks it would honestly it would
probably be almost
two to three hours a night most times
five hours on a weekend but
so 20 hours a week yep and six months we
made 22k
okay all right wow wow very very good
it's like three thousand bucks a month
it would be
very helpful yeah working 20 hours a
week yeah that's pretty strong
that's awesome that's more than some
people may get their job yeah i mean dad
gum
good way to go you guys you're awesome
man
this is so cool so i'm sure mom and dad
are cheering you along when this is
happening right
anybody tell you you're crazy y'all are
young are your friends like you were
they're
paying off their debt or were you all
stupid we're not as extreme
okay it gave us a little grief but they
were always encouraging too
and everyone with the zero percent
student loans right now
everyone's just letting them sit not
touching them we're like let's just go
after it
get them out of the picture so we can
save for our house and just have be debt
free for the mortgage
yeah wow good for you you guys are so
fun
hard work pay off my debt start my life
off right
there's hope there's hope america there
are people like them out there
there's hope how old are you guys i am
25.
i'm 23. that's amazing
i love it i love it and some of you 63
year olds
need to listen to that 23 year old oh my
god this is awesome
very well done well we got a copy of
legacy journey for you because there's
no doubt you are going to leave a legacy
your mom and dad already have heidi and
uh you guys are setting up your own now
it's very very powerful and
another copy of total money makeover for
you to give away to one of your friends
get them moving
that's good stuff you can pay it forward
a little bit well done
all right heidi and matthew wow
from grand rapids michigan what heroes
34 thousand dollars paid off in
18 months making 88 to 120
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
wow grand rapids michigan
might have i mean that that community
i love grand rapids we've been going up
there and doing events for years yeah
we've done a ton of
hard working yeah they believe in hard
work
yes i've just never met a lazy person in
grand rapids there may be one or two up
there
but i've never met them there's just
something about the whole dutch reform
movement the whole
the background of that city and the way
people think they're
hard work is the answer to everything i
love it i love it i love it i love it
yes you can do this no
you are not a victim no you are not
entitled
you need to be matthew and heidi you can
do this
i love it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones triple eight eight two five
five
two two five jared is with us in
sacramento hi jared welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave hi chrissy thanks for uh taking
my call sure what's up
um so basically i was wondering if i
could get a little bit more info i've
completed step one through four
i have my uh as a six month emergency
fund
i've been starting to invest around 15
i have no debt um but i also don't have
a house
and i've already completed the college
that i'm looking to complete
so i'm kind of looking for a next step
here if that makes any sense because i
don't necessarily
think i'm going to be buying a house
anytime soon i would pile up
cash for that purpose beyond the 15
15 of your income into retirement and
then we're heading on to baby step six
which is pay off your house and in your
case
you're not ready to buy yet so you're
just piling up cash how old are you
i'm 21. good okay jared first of all
great job
yeah that's amazing what's your degree
in
thank you uh so i have an aaa in
communications and i'm not necessarily
looking to get my bachelor's quite yet
um but i just got that finished up uh
about a month ago
cool so what are you doing and what do
you make
so i make 50 000 after tax right now
and i live off of about 1200 so roughly
i'm putting about 2800 into savings
every month so that's
exceeding the 15 um
so right now i have ten thousand for an
emergency fund twenty thousand liquid
and five thousand in stock
you know i've kind of just been working
on points throwing the money but i
didn't really
i know what uh phenomenal well what i
would be doing is putting 15
into retirement plans do you have a 401k
at work is that what you're using
i don't uh my work doesn't have a 401k
on just uh
okay are you using a roth ira
i am yeah i haven't done my uh full
amount for the year
okay all right so you're maxing that out
and then beyond that what you're saving
is for a future house purchase if you
think it's going to be five years
three to five years then you know you
can you could use an index fund just an
s p 500 no commission
no load fund just to throw some money
and it'll grow it whatever the market
does
uh since you're playing some stocks and
stuff that might be a better route than
playing those stocks
and it might be a better route than just
a simple savings account but
if you're gonna buy fairly soon three
years or less
then i really wouldn't do that i just
pile it into a savings account but it
sounds like you're just kind of
you know god you're just a guy who lives
frugally
yeah and doing awesome especially for
that young the other thing jared
about a house purchase that is so great
if you start early then it's less
stressful and you can put more down so
you're just in a better financial
position
whenever you do decide to buy a house
you've got more options you've got more
that you're putting into it so starting
now is not a bad thing
yeah i mean if you do 30 000 a year for
three years that's you know you're gonna
be bumping up to a hundred thousand
bucks
uh and you know if you did it for six
years you could probably pay cash for
something yeah
you know and just depends on what you
want to do here uh that's not a bad play
at all
great job great job lori is in charlotte
north carolina hi lori how are you
i'm good thank you dave good how can i
help
okay i'm 36 single mother of three no
village completely on my own
in the past nine months i've paid off 17
000 a little over
in debt using taxes and stimulus you
know
um i relocated here from alabama
just to get out of the situation that i
was in
and um i'm kind of stuck now so i'm kind
of needing guidance on where to go
what do you mean you still have a house
but uh i have a mortgage
so in alabama i have a house i have had
it since i was 19. i purchased it when i
was 23
and it has a leaky roof the roof is only
seven years old it's due to
insulation error i've had three
contractors come out and say the same
thing
so i'm kind of like you know here i was
paycheck to paycheck just like i did
there
um what's the house what's the house
worth about 30
the i'm going to say about 80. it's
actually about to be a prayer okay so
here's the thing i'm trying to get a
refinance to get that
that leak fixed to get the roof done no
just sell it
that's my question well i i don't want
to sell
i knew you're going to say that my child
doesn't want to sell it's also my safety
net if something happens here i mean i
am here really not a safety net it's got
a leaking
roof and it's in alabama
yeah well i don't plan on staying in
north carolina forever
i guess i'm just keeping it you when you
go back you can buy something safe
yeah it's not it's not you know you
that's an illusion honey
it's not a safety net it's a problem
it's a headache
yeah even if you go back to al who knows
what you're going to do
what are you on uh
49. okay well let me tell you what a
safety net is 30 000
cash in the bank and no hassles
and then in three years five years 10
years 12 years you want to go back to
alabama go back to alabama and do
something then you're not going to want
to go back to that house anyway
necessarily
you're going to have a different plan at
that time
okay i think you're holding on to
something holding on
there's something in your head that
you're hoping to show you connect that
this was the first
success you had after a bunch of
failures
buying this house was like a triumph
it's all i've ever known yeah i mean it
but it was your it was your first big
win right
yeah and turning loose so it feels like
you're like you're not gonna be winning
anymore because it was your first big
win
but my point is it was your first not
your last
and you know whether you own a home
somewhere
in the past is an indicator of winning
but
now it's not now it's a problem it's
causing you headaches
you know and you do whatever you want to
do kiddo but you call me
and you're gonna get what i you know
you're gonna get my opinion when you
call here that's why we call it the
ramsey show
so um if if you're my little sister
and you are i i would tell you it's a
stupid house
get rid of it and you know you don't
need it
it represents something emotionally that
would be good for you to figure out how
that is because you can hear it in your
voice
yeah yeah even just the language of like
i'm kind of stuck or here's the problems
i got rid of this
but i think that if you ask yourself the
most basic question
the the benefit and the cost what are
you getting from that house right now
nothing but headaches yeah it's not
doing anything
for you other than this attachment you
have to the past but you could have 30
000
in your bank account which would give
you a actual cushion
with options and then in the future you
decide what you want to do then wherever
you want to be alabama or anywhere
and you do that at that time lori the
irony is is your safety net leaks
oh you're so ready for that i can see it
you had a twinkle in your eye you were
getting excited about that one
your safety net leaks yeah that's a
problem right there
so and you know you left alabama you you
told us but you didn't tell us there was
crap going on there yeah
yeah i had to get away from there i
think she'll feel free if she sells it i
think
she doesn't imagine that but i think she
will feel free after the fact she has
the cash in the bank
and then we're going to close the door
on that headache and that season of life
in a very positive way there's a reason
the windshield is bigger than the rear
view mirror
you need to look forward more than you
look backward
and it's this is going to be good for
you
um you have placed emotional value of
some kind on this house that it doesn't
deserve
that it's not worthy of yeah your secret
sauce lorry is not this house that you
put the money in your pocket and sell
the stupid alabama house
it's a stupid house in the roof leaks
get rid of it
that's what i would do you can do
whatever you want to do and we'll still
be friends
but that's what i would tell you to do
so and i just did
you know it is so i mean you
you were raised by single mom single
moms are warrior princesses man
i mean they fight scratch claw and to
finally
get that accomplishment i got to buy a
house right
that's what i've kind of felt like that
that's right right sorry and i think it
represents too
this source of stability of like i own
this and i don't own something
here so that's what even the word safety
nets like it feels like that feels more
stable because i own it
but it's a source of problems you know
what i mean like this is a new season
and it's time to reevaluate what's right
for us right now that may have been
right then
but what it is now is a headache when
things i tell people
when things change things need to change
so things change
it's time to change that was deep thank
you stitch that on a pillow
stitch that and put it in a frame in the
kitchen when things change
things need to change i mean it's true
this is why we get the big bucks
i love it uh christy wright my co-host
this day here on the ramsay show james
charles is our producer kelly daniels
our associate producer and phone
screener i
am dave ramsey rose and we will be back
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us kristy wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book
business boutique is my co-host today as
we take your questions about your life
and about your money we are
open for business at ramsey
we're here and we're going to be there
too and we're not going
yes and we're getting yeah i'm i'm so
excited to get back out on the road
we're launching uh christy's business
boutique
event which happens every fall here in
nashville
it goes on sale today october
14th through the 16th mark your calendar
go ahead and get your tickets it does
sell out every single year but here's
the great news
you can join us here in nashville in
room which i highly recommend because
the energy in that room oh yeah
is unlike anything else that we do a
room full of 3 000 women we are
excited we are chasing our dreams
together and then we're also
going to do a live stream option so you
can join us either way
but we are going to have another
incredible lineup of rockstar
speakers we love giving you experts
on the topics that you need help with
the most so sales
money management marketing social media
we want to give you
everything you need to start or grow
your business
so whether it's a side business a small
business it's just you as a solopreneur
or freelance worker
a home-based business whatever that
looks like for you we want to give you
the
information and the inspiration that you
need to win
and dave you've spoken at this several
years this is one of those things that
what happens in the room what happens
throughout those three days
is more than just people getting the
tactics and the plan we give them that
but there's something that shifts
in their belief about themselves and i
think that might be the most powerful
part of it
hope deferred makes the heart sick but
when desire comes
it is the tree of life when you you see
people come in
questioning their hope yep and
and the question gets answered yes it
gets confirmed
on these ladies that where they're going
it's equipping women to make money doing
what they love the business boutique
event october 14 through 16.
kristy wright anthony o'neal me jasmine
starr
is a force of nature yes she's she's
speaking for yeah
what does bianca do she's a faith-based
speaker so in the bible world we'd love
to have some sessions on faith and
inspiration and she's a brilliant bible
teacher
and so we we love to wrap up friday with
that and we're so excited we haven't had
her before
nona jones is uh she really leads the
whole
church division of facebook she created
it and so she knows facebook really well
no social media
and then jasmine star she spoke i think
it was two years ago but she
brought the house down and she's an
expert on social media
as well and then of course we'll be
hitting all those other topics between
you
me anthony and um and and our other
speakers so it's it's it's a
very well-rounded event three days and
it's only 119
come to nashville make it a getaway make
it a retreat for you
if you can't do that and you have to do
live stream it's 89
to do that text boutique to 33 789
the other big event boutique two three
three seven eight nine
the other big event is next week uh man
we're gonna be may 16 through 19.
the entree leadership summit is sold out
but you can watch it as a live stream
and you're gonna want to because george
w bush will be with us
yes that's going to be incredible jocko
willink a retired u.s navy seal officer
will be with us
incredible speaker teacher on leadership
john maxwell
one of the best-known leadership
speakers teachers authors in america
today craig groschel
founder and pastor of life.church one of
america's largest churches and a
world-class leader
in his own right all of these guys are
good friends they're all the people that
i listen to the people i listen to their
podcasts i read their books
patrick lincione we've been friends for
years this guy the ideal team player is
a game changer
the advantage is a game changer his new
book the motive is a game changer marcus
buckingham
strength finders is a game changer dr
adrian sternberg spoke here the other
day
at our offices and brought the house
down she's a leadership expert and
speaker
be with us our ramsey personalities me
of course ken coleman christy will be
doing a session dr john deloney will be
doing a session
it is going to be sold out it is sold
out it's going to be a blown up deal
i've got a room reserved here we've got
200 our 200 top leaders in our company
are going to be spending
all three days watching the live stream
yeah
and if you want to
get the live stream for your team to
watch
you can do that it's 350 bucks and you
can register
text summit to 44 222.
this is one of the top three to five
maybe the top
uh experiential uh leadership events
in the nation today uh it is
unbelievably powerful
incredible way to invest in your team
yeah you know if you if you live stream
this for your whole team it what
we've seen in years past when business
leaders and business owners do this
is this event becomes a catalyst
for transformative conversations you
begin to have different dialogue based
on the sessions and what you learn and
it can really change your business
because you all watch it and you're
playing from the same playbook from the
best of the best together so it's so
powerful to see the whole team get on
the same page this way well it's what
happens to us
it happens to us and we just and we put
on the event but i mean we get
patel and johnny's ideal team player
that construct on hiring the right kind
of people
you know hungry humble and smart and pat
and i've talked about it here on the air
and it's
you know it just became part of the
dialogue inside ramsey after that yes
how to lead and how how to properly run
how to build culture inside your
organization
i'm just finishing up jaco's new book
and giaco's man he's on he's on fire
right now
he uh hit his step-by-step
cookies on a shelf where everybody can
reach them leadership ideas are
just like i get it again yeah yeah and
it becomes part of your vernacular
because
you learn it you adopt it and before you
know it you forgot where you got it but
it just becomes part of who you are yeah
and and that's what we want to do with
you here and uh george w was with us
uh in dallas a couple of years ago when
we did this event i did the interview
ken coleman will be doing the interview
this year
uh because his bucket list for him and i
couldn't take it away from him so i've
already done one so he gets to do this
one but
uh president bush's uh
in a setting like that it will blow your
mind yeah
it just it will blow your mind so be
sure you check it out you can uh
text the word summit to 44 222 if you
want to participate
in this live stream may 16 through 19
for your company for your leadership
team summit to 4422
and of course if you want to come to
nashville ladies and be part of the
business boutique
you text the word boutique the
conference business boutique conference
you text the word boutique to 33
789 33 789
so and of course you can just go to
ramseysolutions.com
and click on shows and it'll drop down
it'll have the business boutique page on
there it'll have this
entry leadership summit page on there
the master series for
some for entre leadership will be next
fall it's on there any of the events
we're doing are always on there and
available under the
shows tab at ramseysolutions.com
because when we do these things we go
big we have a blast
and i got to tell y'all after 2020 we're
ready
to get back on some stages we are ready
to get back out there with you guys
we miss you guys and we're excited to do
this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
[Music]
firsts
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show chrissy wright ramsay
personality is my co-host today open
phones at
eight eight two five five two two five
sherry's in allentown pennsylvania hi
sherry how are you
hi there dave christie thank you so much
for taking my phone call how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
yes i was calling because my husband and
i we make 152 000 a year
we have and we're in baby step two so we
have thirteen thousand left for our
cardinal
and then i have a forty two thousand
dollar irs bill
that i pay 532 dollars a month towards
uh for 2020 we get out taxes and i got
another
16 000 added to that bill but i did take
the eye of the reset
i attended that and you said to identify
the big bad wolf
and for me that was the irs so i did
start this year the estimated tax
payments for them so i won't
have that issue anymore after 2020. you
have 100 000
in irs debt no no
it is uh 42 plus 60.
plus sixteen one four oh sixteen
okay i feel i feel a little better i'm
still can't breathe but i feel better
okay
yes okay yeah so 58 on the irs and 13 on
a car
all right i'm with you okay and i have
seven thousand dollars in the emergency
fund which i know it should only be a
thousand
so the reason why we have that is
because we're down to one car
but i've been able to work with that
because i see my clients
tell or zoom and if i need to see them
when i have the card versus them fridays
i use you know i'll use the card so
that's six thousand dollars
extra i want to know should i leave it
there
or should i put it towards that um 13
000 to bring it down to seven which is a
number i like a lot better
or should i put it towards that new
sixteen thousand dollar irs bill to
bring that down to ten
because i wasn't sure if the irs bill
should be in a category by itself in the
sense of urgency to get rid of it
when is this was the 16 when is it to
you is it from
the filing you're getting ready to do
from 2012 yes
i filed and i owe 16 for 2020.
you've already filed yes
before you had to
um yes because i knew i was going to owe
because my husband when we looked at his
um w-2
they only took out 380 for the whole
year so we knew we were going to be kind
of messed up
i wanted to see how messed up i was
going to be and start planning today you
could have done it all and not filed it
though
um because you made the taxes do you
when you filed it they weren't they
weren't due until
it'd be next week anyway but ah geez
well your penalties and interest on that
16 are going to be mammoth i generally
put the irs at the top of the list
in this case i'd put the 16 irs at the
top of your debt snowball
and i would attack it with a vengeance
and let's get rid of it before it starts
getting
if you can get that cleared up within uh
90 days and you should be able to by
putting this six towards it
or seven towards it then then uh you get
that out of your life
then we'll go and knock out the car then
we'll go and knock out the last irs one
because you've got it on a payment plan
but you're getting hammered by these
people with penalties and with taxes so
we generally put the irs at the top
in this case i would put the 16 at the
top because as you said the urgency
yes okay i will do that now you have
corrected all of this
there's no more tax breaks
and he told me exactly how much i need
to be putting away you know so for them
i did my first one in april so
they got paid i did my state in my city
all the time estimated they were small
but
i don't know that one scripture i love
the scriptures i wanted to give caesar
what through season i felt they were
getting too much but then i don't have
to pay at the end of the year it was
like i'm doing now so
well you don't want to be penalized
you're going to be penalized if you
don't pay the proper amount
of and you're going to get a hit with
interest on these
as well when you don't pay the proper
amount of uh
quarterly estimates and you haven't been
doing it for a while
yes yeah so you're paying yeah this is
not about
this is more like if you want a
scripture be diligent to know the state
of your flocks and herds
which means get your act together that
means get your act together
you know you need to start paying the
proper taxes at the proper time
no more but no less
yes and that would be your scripture to
lean on how does the payment plan work
dave like for the 40 for example you
said there's interest on that
like if someone puts on if someone gets
on a payment plan because they don't
have the taxes the amount that's due
yeah they can get on payment plan but
there's going to be fees yeah there's
going to be penalties and
interest and that 42 is just horrendous
i mean it's horrible
if you could get a credit card and pay
it off on a credit card you'd be better
off really wow
it's that bad wow and you don't want the
irs the kgb in your life
right they just have unlimited power man
to screw you up and so yeah you really
can't you know you're not gonna have
peace
in your finances as long as you're
monkeying with those people yeah
so not only getting rid of the debt but
also getting the right amount of taxes
done at the right time in the right way
and
not depending on them to be competent or
kind
because they generally are neither and i
mean there's people that work there that
are occasionally but in general the
agency is not
it is not their purpose in life to
minister to your little heart
so um our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible
deal today's question comes from
jennifer in pennsylvania
i have a side hustle and charge a fair
price for my product
some of my customers are not financially
secure and i feel bad taking their money
if i lower my prices it wouldn't be
worth my time to do it
how can i stop feeling guilty for
selling to them so this is an
interesting question i hear that same
phrasing dave when i hear people talking
about
any type of sales they say i don't want
to take people's money well first of all
you're not
taking people's money they're giving it
to you because of the value of the
product or service you provide but the
other thing i would add to this is
if you're getting the wrong customer you
might need to look at your branding and
your marketing to get a customer
that can afford what you're doing
because you can't do it at a lower price
you're already charging a fair price
maybe yours there's something mixed up
in your messaging that you are
attracting customers that cannot pay
what you're charging and they're not a
good fit for you then so you change your
messaging to get a different customer
that can afford
the price that you're charging which is
fair to you the the what we tell people
all the time david
the price that you charge should be fair
to you as a business owner
and fair to the customer needs to be
fair both ways but
this idea that you're responsible for
their money management you're not
but you may want to look at your
marketing if you're if you're getting a
lot of pushback that you know these are
not the right customers
there's a not a right fit what would you
add yeah
or what are you reading into that
i don't i i can't tell all that's going
on here
honestly i'm just sitting here but you
know some of my customers
are not financially secure and i feel
bad taking their money
uh the grocery store where they buy food
does not feel bad
yeah taking their money for the food and
they didn't rip them off
now if you're ripping them off yes
that's another thing right
okay you're not oppressing the poor i
mean if you're a payday lender
you're screwing the poor right okay
that's that's not good that's
horrible yes horrible business if that's
what you're doing then
don't do that you know but don't and
don't overcharge them
don't oppress the poor if somebody's not
i don't know what you mean by not
financially secure most americans aren't
financially secure
just about everybody yeah you know uh
and so
you know i own a pizza place i don't but
i mean if you own a pizza place you only
sell to financially secure people you
may not sell many pizzas right
right so but you it's not your job to be
their
mommy and their daddy and their nanny
that's right uh and so
your job sell pizzas right and your job
sell groceries
and whatever it is you do but again now
the other thing you can do
is out of your profits when you set your
f
price at a good fair price
you can turn back around and say i'm
gonna donate a certain percentage of our
goods or our services to someone
yeah that is truly in need right and
that generous heart is fine
but to adopt your whole business or to
build your whole business model
around other people's decisions you
can't do that
it's impossible to anticipate that yeah
they're not responsible for it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
at matt is with us in chicago hey matt
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thanks for having me on i uh i
appreciate you uh having me on i'm
able to ask these questions in part
thanks to you so
i appreciate it sure how can we help
yeah um so to give you some context
uh i'm two years out of college and and
i finally
snowballed uh all my dead away you know
as of
the last six months way to go dude how
much did you pay off thank you
about 35 000 and 20 that was
my student loans you know the other half
of my college my parents
picked up the buck on the first half and
uh and the rest of it was just
between you know moving expenses
paying off some car repairs and things
like that congratulations well done
so where does that bring us to today how
can we help
yeah so i mean today you know
for me it was always you know discipline
equals freedom i learned that from this
great book i read
and that's what got me to this point and
uh now that i have
you know no deaths you know now that i
have that freedom
uh i i'm looking at all the goals i want
you know the
ring that you know my girlfriend soon to
be you know wife in the next couple
years deserves and
you know a new a new car on the horizon
and you know a house you know down the
road you know being able to have money
um you know to share in my marriage to
you know put on the table and contribute
to that and it's
it's crazy because you know i almost
feel like with the debt
it was easier because you could see it
and you know i climbed the mountain
and i feel like a buffoon because
there's just another huge mountain in
front of me
and and i don't know how to manage my
money for myself
instead of managing it for my debt now
and i'm really just kind of lost and and
i don't know how i start managing that
money for myself with these
kind of invisible goals well they're not
invisible they're very tangible
and there's too much they're not you're
acting like it's unattainable or
something or it's too invisible they're
not invisible they're right in front of
you it's a ring
they're just not holding you hostage
like the debt was yeah that's the only
difference
there's no nobody got a gun to your head
anymore christie's right
so yeah i mean you just you're going to
prioritize house
ring car we in what order are we going
to do this
and what are we going to spend on each
and put a dollar amount beside it
just as if you were paying off a debt
and then you just build up that savings
and knock out that item build up that
savings knock out that item build up
that savings
knock out that item while you're working
the baby steps which you're at baby step
four
you're putting 15 of your income into
retirement
uh and you have your emergency fund in
place uh and so you know if you've got a
timeline on this ring
or a timeline on this car i'm guessing
one of those two is the first of the
three
and the other one is the second of the
three and the house is the last one and
you don't
you're not in that big a hurry on the
house but everything about 15 we can
find in the budget we just pile in there
and uh you don't have to be as intense
as you are getting out of debt but you
do need to be intentional
and you also need to budget some money
to enjoy your life while you're at these
stages
uh and generosity you know it's
interesting because i think when you're
in debt
the uh debtors are you know all the
people that have your debts are telling
you when to pay where to pay and what
the amount's gonna be
right like they they hold you hostage
they tell you all the rules you have to
play by their rules
well to to matt's point now he's free
and he has these goals and he gets to
decide the amount
and the timeline and that's exciting but
it can also be intimidating
so dave i'm curious when it comes to
buying a ring buying a car
do you have guidelines on like
percentage of income or a certain amount
or that type of thing in terms of to
give matt some guidance of like here's
here's
here's what i would recommend or is it
just kind of whatever you know he could
obviously cash flow and
you know what he's number one number one
where we pay cash
or we don't do it right uh on a ring one
time your salary one month one month of
salary okay there's plenty
one months of income is plenty that's
that's plenty big enough ring there is
you know there is no correlation
statistically in any piece of research
between the size of the ring and the
quality of the marriage
as a matter of fact at certain point the
size of the ring might have an inverse
so um but the uh you know
we got married on a .23 it's in the safe
now
she's got a headlight on her hands now
but we got married on a 0.23 carat i
mean it's a tiny little speck of a
diamond
1166 bucks and uh big dollars
and there's a lot of money back then uh
and i probably paid too much for it but
anyway i did
and so you can do whatever you want to
do there but that's a good guideline and
as we all know on the show we talk about
don't buy cars that are worth more than
half your annual income
uh things with motors wheels and uh
whatever they go zoom zoom you just not
not more than half your annual income
tied up because they go down in value
and don't get caught up in a ring of
diamonds or investments they're not
i bought a bunch of them for ms sharon
over the years and they just don't go up
in value it's just a bunch of crap the
only thing i bought them for is for her
i didn't they're not investments it's
not like he was getting rich on diamonds
not even
not even close quite the opposite yeah
not not the deal so yeah and you know
certainly on a house the more you can
save the better yeah because the quicker
we get it paid off yeah it's an
interesting question though because it's
like oh man i'm so used to following
everybody else's rules now i get to make
my own rules
set my amount my timeline my goals this
is where the budget
comes into play because you budget for
entertainment you budget for
fun you budget for generosity and you
budget for
savings towards these individual goals
and so you still have
a game plan yeah and you know we used to
laugh and say you know we're planning
our impulses
yeah you know because we you know we're
going to set some money aside for random
acts of generosity
and just catch somebody and you know buy
their coffee buy their groceries pay
their meal
you know whatever just do something just
have some pocket money for that and so
budget for that put it put that stuff in
there yeah that's the discipline he was
talking about right
like that the budget is the discipline
that gives you the freedom to spend what
you want to spend where you want to
spend it it really is and it's not like
you're it's
not like some kind of constrictive
discipline because you get to set the
rules yeah
you have to decide which how much you're
going to put in generosity how much
you're going to save towards the ring
you get to decide this so it's not the
difference is you're not being held
hostage like you said by the debt
right garland is in baltimore hi garland
how are you
i'm good dave hi christy hi um
um you're one of my faves because i'm a
woman business owner
awesome um i live
in a different world than my brother my
father died in january
due to covet sorry yeah
he was 97 so he had a long
wonderful life um
my question is um he left me an
inheritance
and i'm living on disability right now
and just got approved i've been living
on basically nothing for the last two
years
because you know um i was waiting on the
disability
and that whole process um my question is
he told me that i should put my money
my inheritance into a um
investment and receive a monthly stipend
and get a mortgage because the mortgage
rates are so low
and i already know what you're going to
say probably
uh how much is your inheritance it's 200
000. how old are you
i am 56. what's the nature of your
disability
um it's both mental and physical i have
fibromyalgia and
ptsd and major depressive disorder
i'm sure so i have good days and i have
not so good days
so i can do like some things at home i
do hand spun wool i make sweaters hats
so two hundred thousand dollars invested
at ten percent is twenty thousand
dollars a year it's fifteen sixteen
hundred bucks a month
right and you're not buying a house
you're not buying a house in baltimore
on that no no no no i live in the
country really that's the closest city
um down down on the delmarva peninsula
if you can get if you can get a
very inexpensive home you can pull that
off
uh but this nest egg you have you cannot
take anything off of the 200 000 unless
it earns it
right i don't think you're going to i
don't think you're going to qualify for
a mortgage
right so my whole thing was i'm debt
free
um i know how to live on a um cheaper
house could you buy
um i was thinking about getting some
land
and putting like one of those barn
dominions on it
no i don't think you need to build
anything you're disabled and got all
these other things going on
you need to just buy something if you're
going to buy something if you could buy
something for 100 pay cash put the other
100
in investments if you can pull that off
that's what i would look at doing
wow you got a lot going on kiddo hope
that gives you a start
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five mary's
in chattanooga hi mary how are you
hi dave and chrissy i'm a nervous wreck
how are you
oh i'm glad you're here you're okay
no trouble we we've never lost a patient
you'll be okay
i love it when you say that i'm supposed
to watch podcast like a yeah there's
actually an app called podcast
addict which is a reason it's called
podcast adding it's quite addictive
well thank you how can we help today hon
crisis mode um i guess we call that
storm mode
and uh just got my top my credit report
is 30 years of wreckage
student loans student loans student
loans credit cards credit cards credit
cards etc to the tune of about 42 grand
and 42 degrees to me is like a bazillion
grand right now because i'm in a budget
where i'm like in a budget freeze if you
will there's not enough money to go
around
at all what do you make
well i'm on disability i get 7.94 a
month to cover everything my rent takes
620 so the math is not good right now
right now i'm not stronger i'm sorry we
have how much coming in on disability
794 a month about nine grand a year
eight to 99 a year yeah
and uh rents rent right now where i'm
paying at 620 a month
which is about six grand plus a year so
how are you eating yeah how are you
living with that
well uh pregnant a lot and
minimalizing very much um and shopping
in my pantry when i have one
um uh food banks once a month we get a
food bank delivery once a month um
yeah i don't have transportation and job
i'm trying to try and address what i can
you know i'm just trying to figure this
whole how do i get a job how do i get on
my feet how do i get myself
this book has like i got this book and
read the tool i'm going to make over an
eight hour straight with potty breaks
and food
and um got myself humor still but um
yeah i'm just really stressed out um
this has separated my marriage it's just
because
it's just been a disaster this past 12
months i've been i've lost four
relatives a friend and
my spouse is separated from me right now
so it's not a good year
or two that was either i didn't cope
with never even came on the radar i was
done with everything else been trying to
do this though how old are you yeah i
don't i'm 51.
what's the nature of your disability
mental and physical ptsd um
chronic back pain so i'm trying to find
something i can
do hopeless
and survive mm-hmm
yeah what's the name when did you when
did you hurt when did you hurt your back
um well i've got four grown kids i've
had a set of twins i
did a lot of uh inappropriate i guess we
call posture issues with lifting and
bending
i've been a factory worker i've just
done everything from retail to fast food
to
just work really hard um i understand
within the last four years in 2016 i
went into treatment i've had four years
pain and sober now so that's changed my
life
and apparently woke up my lookup call to
my budget congratulations
my but my budget was out of shape too
hey wait a minute stop it stop a minute
you've been dry how long uh
8 29 16. way to go i'm proud of you
that's a big deal thank you it was that
story in the big page 289 fear of fear
when i thought it was my husband was not
going
out with me and that was the thing i
never wanted to because i grew up around
that
all over the place it's all over my
family oh i'm proud of you
so that's a win let's mark that down in
the wind column because you got a bunch
of stuff in the lose column right now we
need a few things in the window that was
all my higher power i had very little to
do with it except for i said
celebrate the birthdays calling me
important i didn't create myself but i'm
celebrating
so here's what we have here here's what
you got to do
you need to start laying out uh small
goals
very very small goals that you can do
like the one day at a time idea
okay um and we're going to just do that
in with the money side of things
and with the um uh
with the career side of things so what
we've got to do is we have to move you
towards an income so we're going to send
you a copy of christie's book
business boutique because i think that
probably the best way to work around a
bad back
and uh and uh
all the things you've had coming at you
is to come up with an
idea that you do as a small business
that you can do yeah with that with
these limitations
but a lot of people their their very
limitations lead them to their best
career
ever yes yeah and let's while we're at
it dave let's send her a live stream
ticket to business boutique i think that
might just be the injection of hope
that she needs right now in this season
of life yeah it'll come up in october
and you'll be able to watch
that we can do both of those things and
then mary the other thing i want you to
do
is um it it just
listening to your voice and all the
things that have come
at you in the last couple of years while
you've remained sober
congratulations again yes but i mean
you've got a marriage issue
you've lost family and friends you've
definitely got an income
issue you're definitely struggling on
the
whole money piece uh and
but there's not a magic pill for 700
income
so we've got to do something that
changes that
for you to have a prosperous future
and because the 620 rent is not out of
line until you tell me you only have 700
coming in
so we've got to buy lights and food and
water and we take care of food and
lights and water before we take care of
anything else in rent before we take
care of anything else
so i think you're going to need more
community in your life than you have had
in a higher quality community and if you
haven't searched out and plugged into a
good church in your area
i think a great church in your area
would consider it an honor to walk
alongside you and help you with some of
these transitions
and some of these uh uh things that
you've got to get started
but you got to have somebody with their
arm around you a little bit saying you
can do it
on a daily basis and i'm not going to be
able to do that every day from the radio
other than just
continue to put the podcast out but um
you're going to have to change something
that creates an income
uh and in order to do that you're going
to have to have healed
more from a lot of these blows you've
taken and you've taken some serious
blows
so uh and it is normal to be hurting
when you go through all the things
you've been through yeah the other thing
i would say dave is as she does this as
she starts to create more
income i believe it's going to inject
hope and confidence into how she
approaches everything because you could
just hear in her voice she's just down
she's just down and discouraged and
defeated and this is wrong and this is
wrong i mean she just breezed past
being sober that long and so so just
continue to build on the winds add to
the winds column i love the way even the
visual of that
and then when you start getting some
income whatever that is whether it's a
a home you know a work from home
situation a part-time job a side
business from home whatever that looks
like for you
i think that's gonna do a world not only
for your finances but for your
confidence like okay
i can i can do this i can get myself
back i can get you know get my life back
i can get it together
and that's really gonna that's gonna
help how you give you the momentum
to attack the next goal the next death
the next thing and
propel you forward yeah i've got several
for i've got two
good friends that have unbelievably
three
that have unbelievably painful chronic
back pain
24 7 they hurt 24 7. and
uh it's very real uh but even they
find something they can do through the
fog of the pain
and you know we had a young couple on
here earlier that i was making three
thousand dollars a month through an uber
each 20 hours a week right
and so just get in the car and go
deliver food right i mean it's not it's
not a big
mental strain uh but three thousand
dollars change your freaking world
right right change your world and so uh
that's the kind of stuff i want you to
be thinking about anything like that to
just get yourself
get your your your back up you're backed
up against the wall and get yourself
away from that wall a little bit get the
wolf push back
and uh so we'll send you christy's book
i'm also going to send you her
devotional
uh 40 days back to you and
um because i i as you said your higher
power
god carried you through this process um
on being sober and that's just so vital
so uh and honey you call us back if you
need help as you go through this
but you've got it what your biggest
crisis is is your income crisis
and all of the uh blows
that you've taken are affecting your
ability
because you're human you're hurting uh
to see your potential income out there
and it's not pollyanna but and in the
meantime get some community around you
get a church to help you
they'll help you there's great churches
in chattanooga tennessee lots of great
churches
so you hold on kelly will pick up and
we'll send you the devotional and the
business boutique book
and a ticket to the live stream as well
but that's not till october so she's
gonna do something before october for
sure
so good question mary thank you for
calling honey and you call again if you
need some help
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book business
boutique is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money
we have launched christy's business
boutique event for the fall
goes on sale today it will be october
14th
through the 16th the business boutique
conference is always a sellout
nashville is a hot destination and uh
certainly this event
has always brought out the ladies
business boutique equipping women to
make money
doing what they love october 14th
through the 16th
yes this is in nashville and we're gonna
have amazing speakers you're speaking
i'm speaking anthony o'neil it's his
first time with us which we're so
excited about
jasmine starr who's a social media
expert nona jones
also social media and marketing bianca
oltof
and she is an awesome faith-based
speaker and we're going to have some
more as well but we're going to cover
all of the topics that you need help
with to start or grow
your side or small business you can join
us in person
or on the live stream to get your
tickets for in room with us in person in
nashville it's 119
the live stream is 89 but you can text
boutique
to 33789 to learn more
and it's going to be fun every single
year we try to raise the bar dave and uh
this year is no exception
there you go very well done good stuff
good stuff
also next week may 16th through the 19th
we will be doing our entree leadership
summit in dallas it is completely sold
out and there is a reason it is one of
the top
leadership events in the nation today
george w bush will be joining us this
year jocko willink retired u.s navy seal
officer
best-selling author joining us john
maxwell best-selling author leadership
expert joining us
craig groeschel founder and pastor of
life.church
one of the largest churches in america
and a world-class leader in his own
right patrick lincione bestselling
author of ideal team player many other
books
marcus buckingham bestselling author
strength finders you know marcus he's
incredible
dr adrian sternberg will be with us
leadership expert and speaker she is a
force of nature
our ramsey personalities ken coleman
will be doing a session christy will be
doing a session dr john dolone will be
doing a session i'll be doing a couple
of them
it is going to be incredible it is a
packed out three-day
experience on leadership our entire
leadership team here
in nashville will be watching it live
stream and we have some live stream
tickets
currently available if you want to have
your team
look in and watch over this three days
it is the way we are doing this your
leadership team a lot of you don't have
formal leadership development programs
to develop your people into leaders
this is the way you do it you put this
kind of content
into minds and hearts and it changes
people to register text
summit to 44 222 text
summit to 44 222 they'll talk to you
about the standard live stream tickets
are currently
available for 1350 and the live stream
plus
pass is only 2 500 you can get the whole
office in there if you want to and get
them in there and watching it
and you know depending on the size of
your operation what you want to do there
but
it's um these are world-class
teachers thought leaders on the whole
subject of business and
leadership and we have a great time
doing this ramsay's open for business
baby
we're back out on the road again thank
you willie
good stuff man good stuff matt is with
us matt is in kansas city hi matt how
are you
i'm doing well dave thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so um there's a couple quick questions
for you
one is regarding my uh my
retirement account i currently have
about a hundred and eighty five thousand
dollars
in my retirement account and i got
um my pension taken out from a previous
employer
and i rolled it into that retirement
account
about a hundred thousand dollars and i'm
just uh
kind of want to get your input on what i
should do with that should i spread it
out
on top of the mutual funds i have or
should i
uh spend an etf or other
stocks or anything like that i spread my
personal retirement accounts
all of them for many sources across four
types of mutual funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth
and international all mutual funds that
have at least a 10-year track record
if you have those in your current
account that you've got this in
then just put it in those okay
uh would it be best to just do it all at
once or should i disperse it over
the course of time what's it sitting in
now
it's just it's just sitting in the
account as cash at the moment
oh okay yeah just definitely get it
invested now
i mean as fast as you can because you're
going to take advantage of the market i
mean the market may go down 10 days
after you invest it
but overall 10 months after you invest
it the average is you're going to make
money on it i mean
you're investing long haul so the sooner
you get in the longer the hall is it's
great
i appreciate them uh just real quick in
my second question my wife and i i'm
sorry i don't have a time or a second
sorry about that
craig finished baby step three a few
months ago
and so we've been putting hi dave so my
wife and i finished baby step
three a few months ago and so we've been
putting 50
15 of our income into retirement we
don't have any kids
we don't currently own a house i'm about
to transition my career and i will be
making substantially more money than
previous to where we will
be no longer qualified to contribute to
a roth ira wonderful
my question is yeah thank you my
question is since we know that we have a
limited amount of time
left to contribute to a roth ira
should we increase how much we are
contributing now
and if we do do we know when we formally
become disqualified like when we get our
first big paycheck or after filing the
higher tax return
income that's just in the calendar year
what your income is
is what it amounts to if your income is
going to exceed 200 000 in a calendar
year you're not going to be qualified
for a roth but you could do back door
roth
i i do a back door roth and i far exceed
that income limit
a back door roth is where you just open
up a i do it every year in january
uh for the year before and um or for
that year i mean
i do it for that calendar year actually
uh but you just open a
traditional ira after
tax not before tax
okay and then instantaneously roll it
into a roth that's called a back door
roth
um it's perfectly legal but it is it's
the way to beat the limit
the income limitation you can't open a
roth but you can roll into a roth with
any income
right and just in the amount of time
that i'm currently making less
than is then would be required for that
should i
increase how much i'm contributing now
since i know that
in like maybe it won't matter it won't
matter if you make more than 200
000 in 2021 you cannot do a roth in 2021
without doing it as a backdoor
gotcha it's not like it's not like you
i'm gonna pass the
veil over in july the 14th and after
that no it's the calendar year
in that calendar year what do you make
if you make too much you can't do a
traditional
you can't take the normal approach to a
raw
you'd have to do a back door roth in
that year which is probably going to
happen this year
your 2021 your 2020 that's last year you
know what that's a known quantity if you
haven't done one you could do one for it
if you haven't filed your taxes yet so
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
thank you for joining us america christy
wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 825.52
two five ellie is with us in our eli
is with us in kansas city hi eli how are
you
good dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so i've scrambled your baby steps a
little bit and i'm prepared to be yelled
at but
i need some advice i like this start
already
right i i listened enough to know
so we have a little bit of a unique
situation my wife and i
we have paid off all of our smaller
debts we have no credit cards no car
payments
no consumer debt except we have
about 62 thousand dollars in a
consolidated student loan
and we have 68 000 left on our home
and i'm wondering my question is
uh we are purchasing our home on
contract for my wife's grandmother it's
zero interest and we have
it was a five-year deal and whatever was
left we have to
get a mortgage for and and you know pay
off the remainder
and so my question is we have one year
left we we will have about 60 000
in excess income over the next year
should i
pay the the contract off on this home so
i can avoid having to go out and get a
mortgage or should i put that
toward my student loan debt what's the
home worth
the home is worth 168. okay you need to
go get
a loan and pay grandma today
this is dangerous dangerous
dangerous because you just told me this
is a land contract you do not have this
house in your name do you
we have a it's a contract for deeds yeah
i know i know what it is it sucks
really bad okay here's the problem
grandma falls asleep at the wheel
hits somebody head-on and get sued for
the injuries
and there's a five million dollar lien
on her it goes against this house that
she owns
you don't own this house you're a renter
okay danger danger land contracts are
horribly uh leave you horribly exposed
if she gets an irs lien placed against
her it goes against
this house it's not your house
it's in her name so go get so go ahead
and go get a mortgage now
this week and just continue on with the
baby steps and pay off the student loans
yes sir yes sir okay but not for the
reasons you thought you were going to
get yelled at but um
but the totally different reason
congratulations
here's yeah so here's the thing you need
to go to a credit union or a small local
bank
you don't need to get a traditional
mortgage for this it's too expensive and
there's no need
you should be able to get the what is
equivalent of a home equity loan but
here's what you're looking for
you need to be very demanding of this
bank or this credit union
write these things down no closing costs
there's no reason for there to be a
bunch of closing costs on a sixty
thousand dollar loan
on a hundred sixty thousand dollar house
this is called a no-brainer loan
okay right no closing costs fixed
rate
no balloons
and so put this to put this on a five
year or a ten year
fully amateurizing meaning when you pay
the payments the loan disappears
without a call or a balloon no call no
balloon
fixed rate no closing costs
and you may have to lean in on the young
manager over at the credit union so they
understand you
because they're not gonna they're gonna
want to put this on some kind of home
equity loan product
with a variable rate where they change
the rate at their whim or it has a put
balloon on it or a call on it
or they're gonna try to sneak in some
closing costs all of which are totally
unacceptable
they will make this loan and they'll be
happy they made it what's a call
a call is is they have the ability to
call the loan anytime they want to
anytime they want they look at it they
go i don't like your
financial situation anymore alone is due
and it turns into like something on the
movies or something then
uh bad movies we own a small business we
do about two million dollars in revenue
and it all runs through our local credit
union and so we have a really good
relationship so hopefully
that would be it should be easy then it
should be easy but
yeah but here here's the thing what i'm
telling them to do
is not the way their minds normally work
so you're going to be
very strong and very clear you have to
be mean about it but it's like no no
no no you misunderstood me fixed rate
no closing costs no call 10-year loan
simple loan
and then you can go pay it off after you
get your student loans paid off as quick
as you want
the beauty of this is it didn't cost you
anything to set this loan in place
yeah and you got rid of all this risk
with grandma
all right we will do that this week and
grandma will be smiling she got her
money and then you pop
knock out those cr knock out those
student loans and reach over and knock
out that tiny mortgage
because you're killing it you're doing
great with your business congratulations
very cool that's good stuff yeah so
contract for
deed or land contract are the same thing
it is simply a contract
that says after you pay these payments
for however many years
then they then they give you the deed
but until then the house is not in your
name
okay and uh it's a way a lot of owner
financing is done
uh but it is dangerous it's not
dangerous for the seller right it's
dangerous for the buyer because the
buyer hadn't bought anything
gotcha and so if if the seller gets
crossways and i've seen this happen
they get a some kind of a financial
catastrophe that you cannot see coming
i mean grandma could fall asleep at the
wheel i mean not because she's drinking
she could just fall asleep you know i
mean right we don't have to call grandma
bad it's just cuz
bad things sometimes happen you know and
so
uh i mean the tire could blow out on her
car yeah and
you know she swerves over and you know
hits something and tears it up and or
some hurts somebody or something
and it's just a horrible called an
accident and yet
the whole thing falls apart over here
because you didn't have the property in
your name it's in her name
and her her problems are going to end up
on you gotcha
and that that's the danger of this it's
very dangerous
because you know in his case he could
lose a hundred thousand dollars yeah
of equity he's got 168 000 household 62
on yeah
but it ain't his house yeah and if this
thing got sideways you could lose all
that so get this done
this week don't ever do those things
don't ever do land contracts contracts
for date ever
ever ever peoples all right mary's in
san diego hey mary what's up
hi i'm sally to talk to you youtube
question today's question
yes so i'm the youngest sibling of a big
family
and my dad's deceased has been for more
than a decade
my mom has dementia and she's in
care i am in charge of a big
family trust my dad left a legacy he was
a great worker a great man
somewhere in between my mom being
diagnosed with dementia and my dad
died i was named trustee rather
i'm the youngest how old are you i'm
almost 40.
okay all right so why were you selected
um they were questionable investments
and questionable handling of money just
in personal life
and then business you know so i think my
mom was
maybe there was a tad of emotion um in
there but
i am i'm level-headed and conservative
okay
all right because you got common sense
that's why you were selected okay
and how big is this truth it's
the money in the bank is at
11 million and then the properties are
probably
brings a state to about 20 something wow
i know well my little family did rice
and beans and bees and rice and we're
good
i have a sweet little family that we
take care of but this is something else
right
yeah and i've been presented with a big
investment opportunity from my oldest
brother
and i'm just struggling with the what is
big
um about half of that 11 million that's
an investment
right now and he wants you to invest in
what
purchase a best friends
company that's going to do double the
business of what they're doing now
it's going to be multi multi-million
uh i heard you say you didn't believe it
i i don't know no you don't believe it
does she i don't believe it either yeah
i don't know much about it but i don't
it hey you're in charge
and you don't need to feel guilty for
being in charge you're put in charge
because you got common sense we may want
to invest some of it rather than sitting
in the bank
but i'm not sure this deal is the right
deal as a matter of fact you're pretty
sure it's not
i don't know anything about it but
you're pretty sure it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
if you've been paying attention the real
estate market in the last year it's
crazy
have you noticed the competition out
there is high inventories are low
yeah these this is not amateur hour you
do not want to be dealing with a real
estate agent i know what the flip
they're doing right now
if you're selling a house you can have
somebody knows how to navigate this
weirdness
if you're buying a house you got to have
somebody that knows how to navigate
this weirdness you need to get a pro and
uh we vet the top agents in your
area we do not let someone become an elp
unless they are proven years of success
lots of volume they don't sell three
houses a year and get to be an elp for
us
so you can instantly connect with an
endorsed local provider in your area
please do not get in this real estate
market and just
wander around like a lost sheep you're
gonna get slaughtered
because it's just bad out there i mean
you you you can
really mess up right now selling or
buying especially selling
if you're going to sell a house get a
high quality somebody
really knows how to work this stuff
because you can you can make a lot
more with somebody that knows what
they're doing anyway go to
ramseysolutions.comagent
ramseysolutions.com agent get in touch
with
one of our endorsed local providers
all right on the stay that free stage
with a question from nashville
is caleb hey caleb what's your question
hey uh i want to say thanks for having
me i know you have to do this um sure so
i hope you can give me some advice here
we'll try so uh my grandma is 72 years
old
she's debt-free house and all her only
assets are her house and his 60 000
cd uh she recently started talking with
her high school sweetheart after 55
years and has just gotten engaged
but the issues are we've ran three
background checks on this guy and he's
found out he's 500 thousand dollars in
debt
largely to the irs other than that we
talked to his ex-wife and
says he has a problem with
over-indulging alcohol being a very
dominant male figure
it has bad financial tendencies
obviously
um the thing is she's not listening to
any of these red flags so she hasn't
felt affection
uh since my grandfather died about 17
years ago and uh she's really flattered
by you know little gifts and stuff that
you know he's giving her
and we we really tried to talk her out
of this but we just don't
she's all this stuff all the red flags
just it's
going one year out the other with her
just because she hasn't felt affection
by a man
and uh i'm just trying to see if you
have any advice for me and how we should
approach this situation before she gets
married wow
well i want to first commend how much
you care about her because it shows that
her family cares about her
so much that y'all would go to that
effort to do the background checks and
think about her and look out for her and
even come here and ask this question so
well done you love her very much
and that shows yeah no that's powerful
you know even as he described it he said
she's 72 yeah
and it's his grandmothers when i think
of a grandmother i think of someone like
you know that's a lot older than that my
mom's 72 dave so this would be like you
know this question my mom i'm like a
60-year-old grandfather shut up
christine
grandparents i think if grandparents is
older but that's my mom
i mean you know yeah yeah so uh the
uh the problem is
not how to smoke the guy out the problem
is she's not willing to do it
um i'll give you some ideas on smoking
him out
uh and he'll run he'll run when you do
this
uh but you but she has to do them
and so uh because you can't you know
it's not illegal to be stupid right
that's the problem
and um
[Applause]
who will she listen to pastor
another friend someone that's wise she's
not listening to her family she's
she has seven kids she's only listening
to one and uh
that one kid has
just came out with our family uh as a
homosexual and that's the only person
that she's listening to and he's the
only one
uh you know our family is very well is
he concerned about
this guy no that's the thing like we're
all he had like a big spotlight you know
we're all
conservative christians i understand but
i'm not worried about him his lifestyle
what i'm concerned about is does he
still have influence with her
and is he questioning also this
relationship
he's not because he's trying to get the
spotlight uh you know he
he has his approval everything no matter
the red flags um
this is like a big fan okay so he's
going along with it he's going along
with okay she's he's he has influence
but he's not
helpful because he wants to go a lot but
because of
the dynamic okay and um
is there anyone that she trusts that
will listen to her that's what i'm
looking for that's it that's the only
person she's not listening to pastor
she's not listening to
friends she's not listening to nobody um
we had
you know this my whole family here this
weekend for mother's day yeah and the
guy showed up and uh it was a
big fiasco but you know just you know we
try to talk to her
and we don't know what else to do and
we're really scared for her yeah i'm
scared for her too because i think she's
been taken
um i don't know how to stop it from
happening
because it's not illegal and uh she just
might got bad judgment that's what it
amounts to
and um and you've outlined why you think
that is and i
you know with what with what you're
telling me i you know
uh assuming all the information you have
is correct um it's a bad situation
obviously she doesn't need to go forward
on but i mean all she would have to do
is just say i need a prenup before
marriage i need to put
everything um over here to the side that
i currently own that you don't have
access to
it to ensure that this relationship is
not about
uh and she could blame it on the family
right she could say so that my family
will shut up
okay maybe you talk to her about that if
anybody's having a conversation with her
that's
that's normal at normal tones without it
screeching and yelling and all this
but i mean if if whoever's having a calm
conversation
hey granny we just here's what y'all do
blame it on me
and tell him that you need to have a
prenuptial
agreement to put all of your assets
aside so that my kids will shut up
now is there a way to where that she has
to have like a co-sign of the family
because okay it'd still be her decision
then her decision to do it yeah or not
do it
yeah is she she's a she's an adult she's
allowed
she's allowed to conduct business and
allowed to get married and allowed to do
all this i mean
unless she has proven incompetent
mentally and you've not mentioned that
no she's not lonely is not mental
incompetence
um needing of affection is not mental
incompetence
uh so you got to go into court and prove
her like if she had alzheimer's or
something you could get her
you could get a guardian appointed to
her by the judge right and then you
would take it or take away her rights to
do transaction
on her behalf because she's not capable
yeah that's why it says this is just bad
judgment this is not any of that
what did she say did y'all present this
with her like the five hundred thousand
dollars of irs didn't know that did
y'all
talk to her about that yeah what did she
say she's almost like she don't even
believe it yeah
and like you know we've even hired a pi
and wow the other day that pi
even told us to because when he showed
up they said you know kidnap your mom
because this is a bad situation wow and
you know it's just like we try to talk
to her yeah well
i wouldn't do that that's a federal
crime okay right right right i'm just
saying like with that
idiot but yeah uh i mean he's i guess
he's just being melodramatic
but i mean uh i might take her on a long
trip though
right a friendly type of kid hey granny
we're going to hawaii for three weeks
okay load her up uh here we go yeah
uh you know if your family has the the
if you can get her
uh out from under his influence long
enough
on a vacation a family vacation or
something but if somebody can just say
granny
listen blame it on me yeah just blame it
on me
that the kid in order for my kids to
shut up i need to do a prenup
because that'll make you sure make you
sure that this guy's real
and if you do that i'll shut up and i'll
stand with you against the rest of
family
and we'll shut up if you'll at least get
a prenup is it once she introduces
prenup to duber
duber's gonna run yeah okay because this
guy's after one thing
that's right that's what we all say too
yeah i think he is i think i think
you've identified that
and i really don't disagree with your
conclusions on that but
wow that is so hard it's so hard
and um yeah and there's a lot of dynamic
going on in the whole family so
wow what a deal hey man thanks for
coming by thank you
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you think he's a
scammer oh yeah
no question and what's interesting is
they can present the prenup idea and not
even have to go through with it because
they'll run it just the threat of it
if shu puts it up there it's a test it's
a test running here's how you can test
him
and how you can shut all of us out
that's right all at once maybe you get
in her ear on that but i don't know
i kind of don't think so i think things
are too melted down now
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today james 1 5 if any of
you lacks wisdom
let him ask god who gives generously to
all
without reproach and it will be given to
him
sandra day o'connor said do the best you
can in every task no matter how
unimportant it may seem at the time
no one learns more about a problem than
the person at
the bottom wow amazing jordan's with us
in salt lake
hi jordan welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave and chrissy thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's up
i just have a question about refinancing
my primary residence
currently just got married um last year
she and my beautiful wife decided to
take on four children
that i that i had into our marriage so
great
um we have this primary residence we
built out the basement
um currently about 250 000 on that
i owned another home before we got
married we currently rent
out that home um owed about two hundred
fifty thousand dollars in that as well
um the primary residence is worth quite
a bit more to work about five hundred
thousand
curious about refinancing um doing a
cash out refine our primary residence
to start paying down that rental home
and start getting more cash flow off of
that
well if we reverse engineer that and say
uh i want to
refinance my personal residence in order
to buy a rental home
that makes me go no you know
and so um the you didn't get into this
rental home
uh because you set out for it to be a
rental home it's by default it was the
old place you used to live
correct yes and currently my parents
actually rent that home so it works out
great for us
oh no it doesn't huh
it's good because they sold their home
to get out of debt that was the biggest
thing so we were like hey you can rent
it and they've
you've never had issues with payment or
anything so yeah
how long is that going to go on um
kind of indefinitely right now they i
told them they could live there as long
as they'd like and
works out great for us um yeah that's
the
the biggest thing is you know we have
equity in both homes obviously more in
our primary residence
a lot larger home um so we're just you
know we can sell that
that rental home for example and maybe
cash out
that's what i was
from it to lower your balance on yours
but now
now you're putting your parents in the
streets so that adds a variable
yeah yeah yeah that's what i woke up
before i heard about the parents i'd
already sold that house a minute ago but
now
now that makes it difficult so uh i just
hadn't gotten around to telling you yet
but
um waiting for a break the uh
uh yeah that so
you know you're gonna be holding that
house as long as mom and dad are in
there i guess
and um if you're gonna be doing that
then we decide okay
we we have no other debt right
correct yeah you have your emergency
fund right and you're putting 15
of your income into retirement then this
is just baby step six
and it just is a matter of which of
these do i pay off why would you
uh what's your current interest rate on
the one you're living in
um so they're both the same 3.375 so
pretty decent
yeah i would just sit on both of them
and let's just pay your
personal residence off first and your
rental off second or
if mom and dad ever do move on then sell
the rental at that point
but um no i would not borrow on my
personal residence to buy a rental or to
pay off a rental either one i'd be more
i'd have more of a tendency to do it the
other way around because i don't put
your
where you live at risk with more debt
uh so we're going to avoid that naomi is
with us naomi
screwed that up all right let's see here
naomi is in fresno hi naomi how are you
hi dave i'm doing well so i have to
connect with you guys how are you
great how can we help
okay dave so i'm kind of lost um
i just got summoned last week
and i'm being sued for two credit cards
for bank of america
and so i talked to an attorney attorney
said
okay in your situation uh we can go
ahead and do bankruptcy uh
chapter seven yeah this would be a
bankruptcy attorney
uh asking a bankruptcy attorney if
you're bankrupt's like asking a dog if
it's hungry
true yeah so how much of the balance on
these credit cards
okay so for in total it's about
uh 13 000 so you don't file bankruptcy
over 13
dollars naomi no why haven't you paid
why haven't you paid them
what uh i'm sorry
why have you not been able to pay them
hun
um i was paying i had a personal loan so
i started paying that
and then i had another credit card with
a citibank so
i started paying that as well and then i
had
foot surgery and then i
had to take on another job which i took
a pay cut
because i moved um so pretty much i just
kind of felt
and uh on my payments yeah so what do
you make now
what do you make now i'm on it uh
i'm on unemployment and i make about two
weeks they give me about fourteen
hundred
okay they're not going to get anything
if they sue you you don't have anything
i don't i don't even have a car they
can't get they can't get unemployment
and i also have another card for capital
one which i owe 5000.
doesn't matter they can't get anything
you don't have anything
so your problem is not your debt your
problem is your income
that you don't have right
i mean if you got a job making 30 000 a
year we can walk you out of this in no
time
yeah anything you're not bankrupt honey
you're trying to live on unemployment
and life is not designed to do that
you have no income right and i'm correct
and i'm moving in two weeks to uh down
to socal
um so i'm hoping that by then maybe two
three weeks i can find
a full-time job and maybe get a little
more income you're moving
right to socal southern california
why you keep moving yeah
because my boyfriend's um
job kind of keeps him moving around so
this is probably like the fourth
time we've moved in like the past
probably three years yeah when are you
figuring out this ain't working for you
it's not working for me so quit
following him around and being broke
yeah i actually thought about it i
actually thought about just
leaving and kind of doing my own thing
and but with my
financial situation it's just been kind
of hard yeah um
the financial situation is you don't
have a job
right and it's hard because of what
because of what you've been doing for
the last three years it might actually
get easier if you could have an income
if you had if you could stay put in one
place and get a job and make some good
money
that could fix this whole thing you can
clean up this debt in no time once you
get your career goals straightened out
and get your life straightened out kiddo
you do not have a debt problem you have
a life problem and a career problem
and your career problem stems from your
life problem
because you're following uber around and
you've got no life
yeah that's pretty much it yeah so at
this point
it's like i really don't know what to do
and i figured maybe you could do you
know if
bankruptcy would be an option no it
doesn't it doesn't help
it doesn't help sweet naomi what helps
sweet naomi is when sweet naomi starts
valuing
sweet naomi's the quality of life over
following duber around
you are worth more than this you are
more valuable than this girl
the only way you get to follow duber to
socal
is when you make more than he makes and
you start telling him what to do
because this is this is drain the the
bone marrow out of your life you have no
money
you have no career you have no income
and you're calling me about filing
bankruptcy on a tiny tiny little amount
of debt
that could be cleared up in no time i
can settle thirteen thousand dollars
that bank of america is suing you on
for probably two thousand bucks but you
ain't seen two thousand bucks in a long
time kiddo
no i do have a savings you have a career
problem
you have to get your income going and
you have to get
you have to value naomi enough to put
naomi at the front of the list
naomi's getting troubled on she's taking
care of everybody but naomi
am i wrong no you're not wrong you're
not wrong it's not like i'm being too
tough on her no
sweet girl seriously sweet girl love
yourself
a little bit it's not a bad thing it's
not being selfish
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus a friend or family member
that needs a daily dose of ramsay advice
in their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you